huge news in the web 2.0 world this is
Gary Vaynerchuk from Wine Library TV
doing 120 seconds about something
besides wine google buys Jack ooh now as
Jack ooh 2.0 dodgeball and I'm gonna do
nothing with it or is Jake ooh the
Twitter like prat app which I actually
know the two founders and taste a little
wine with them in San Francisco not too
long ago is this a part of a much bigger
scheme by Google to take the world by
storm but really Facebook's world by
storm on November 5th and that's where
I'm going I'm going with the ladder I
think November 5th is going to be a
crossroads in the social networks world
I think Orkut 2.0 which is where Google
is going with this I think is going to
get Facebook a huge scale now Facebook
with our amazing app platform is doing
some amazing things and growing like
crazy getting very close to going public
because we're getting to those dollars
we're gonna have to report anyway so you
know they're going in that direction
I think this Google move is very curious
and very serious I think we're gonna see
a totally different 2.0 platform out
there and I think that Facebook has some
real real fears to see what Google does
with this Orkut 2.0 with the use of juku
their new edition is going to be a very
serious player and competitor to
Facebook ah it's so nice to talk about
something besides wine this is my 120
seconds of something else